all right so opening weekend of Dark
Phoenix is coming to a close not a lot
of people saw that movie did you see
that movie now good for you if you did
see it I'm sorry but if you saw it you
liked it glad you had fun
boys you had fun there's matters for you
but at this point I figured I would just
rank the x-men movies because seeing
other people rank the x-men movies and
I'm like what a good idea thing
that'll be different for this one is I'm
not actually including the Deadpool
movies do you like to see them as
different movies I don't see them as
x-men movies I know it's a couple of
x-men are in Deadpool doesn't change the
fact that I just fundamentally see
Deadpool as different movies in x-men
movie it's kind of like if I were
ranking x-men comic books you can have
x-men comic books with Deadpool in it
but I wouldn't rank Deadpool comic book
stories with the x-men comic book
stories just because we're in the same
universe if I were ranking the Iron Man
movies
I wouldn't put spider-man homecoming on
that list although Iron Man is in
spider-man homecoming just alas it you
may disagree if you do cool also New
Mutants is supposedly going to come out
and I'm doing this before that but I'm
only 5050 as to whether or not that
movies actually going to come out but
that said for the x-men movies I am
rankings there are ten of them which
means this is prime for a countdown so
let's start the list starting from worst
to best starting with no boots today
starting off at the bottom of the barrel
is the recently released that's right
Dark Phoenix if I'm being honest with
myself Dark Phoenix and what I have for
number nine are probably tied for very
different reasons but tied nonetheless
but since this is a fresh taste in my
mouth it just feels worse it just did
nothing for me except it made me feel
like the third human back in Human
Centipede oh well I was pretty mummified
waiting for word to end this but we had
no direction it's just cheese from start
to finish in all the boring ways nine
number nine x-men origins Wolverine
cheese from start to finish and all the
cheesy ways this movie's asked the x-men
movies were spearheaded by Wolverine
they were like let's take his origin
story which is a great compelling one
and really just kind of on it and
by kind of I mean absolutely though my
first video that I ever did on YouTube
was actually Transformers Revenge of the
Fallen x-men origins Wolverine inspired
me that maybe like I want to rant about
this I'm not going to I'm not
interesting and then by Transformers
Revenge of the Fallen I was like alright
I'll do it this movie definitely had a
hand in that though so thank you origins
Wolverine maybe that's the thing that it
has over Dark Phoenix
I don't know that though no age
next up x-men 3 the last stands or Dark
Phoenix only done better never thought
I'd say that I always thought I was
professed I was wished I always hoped I
always knew that if they ever did Dark
Phoenix after x-men 3 the last and it
would certainly be better it wasn't this
movies actually better than dark Phoenix
it actually at least had a plot driving
it forward the whole they found a cure
for the mutant gene that's actually a
compelling plot it's just in an ass of a
movie in the bottom tier like this you
find anything you can cuz that's what I
can find here no movie
next up x-men apocalypse I actually
enjoyed this movie for what it was that
this was the one where I was like well I
could have fun with it and for me
apocalypse wasn't bad like the ones
below apocalypse on this list I mean it
had none of the depth or drive that the
x-men movies above it on this list had
completely wasted apocalypse he wasn't
menacing he wasn't scary wasn't
terrifying he didn't feel like the
apocalypse so it all depends on your
mood when I reviewed this one I was like
I AG enough fun with it I've put it on
in the background while I'm editing and
that's perfectly fine as well fine is
the word to describe apocalypse number
six next up is the Wolverine this is the
one I actually defend their people who
were like the Wolverine the last
act of the Wolverine kind of falls apart
when he starts fighting a silver samurai
robot essentially but a little out of
the rest of the movie I really dug where
Logan starts out in this movie is kind
of a nomad then he goes to Japan a lot
of people wanted to see him in Japan
granted they already did that strike I
feel like if they did the Wolverine now
they'd be like chronology is so
we'll just put dust strike in and I know
she was in x2 so what yeah I actually
dug this one but in a world where I
understand the last act of a movie can
make or break a movie the last act of
this movie broken for you I get it but
the last act of the Wolverine didn't
compromise the first two acts for me so
I walked out go and yeah that was pretty
kick-ass number five x-men the first one
it's great I don't even give a I've
seen people like it doesn't hold up I've
watched it recently until it does I
remember watching the first x-men movie
when it came out and I was like comic
book movies aren't supposed to be this
good but I really had that nostalgia in
my brain I really dug what they did with
Wolverine I thought Hugh Jackman was a
great representation of him which is why
when people were like this person that
cast is whatever character is too tall
or too short Hugh Jackman is way too
tall to be Wolverine
he's not as cut as Wolverine I remember
going into this movie like oh that's not
Wolverine then I saw the movie and I was
like no I can get behind him and in this
first x-men movie who doesn't empathize
with Magneto
you totally get where he's coming from
didn't expect that I'm just used to
villains being villains in comic book
movies this was like no you're an
empathetic villain you're a dick you've
grown about it the wrong way
but I see the leaps you've taken to get
there that was new to me when I watched
the first x-men movie there was even a
twist you dear boy whoever's comic-book
movie they really tried to take
seriously in a time where they didn't
have to and that mindset is something
back ceman movies lose as time went on
and they would get back again which is
nice and then they'd lose it again point
is the one that started it all still
like it for what's better than the first
x-men movie the second x-men movie x2
x-men United is proper sequel without
any of the sequel itis delves deeper
into the intrigue that is Wolverines
pass if they kept completely vague in
the first movie the bad guys have a
team-up with the good guys to take out a
common enemy
solid sequel one could argue great
sequel and great movies it look like the
x-men movies would never go down they
had momentum for days that would last
ages hello but for what we'll call the
first wave of x-men movies this was the
pinnacle it was the best of them next up
x-men Days of Future past
Days of Future past and what I have for
number two that's the immortal war of
what is better I love both it's part of
me that wants to be like I flipped a
coin to decide for this video I kind of
did but I didn't but I kind of did I
flipped a mental coin anyway like I'm
just gonna go for this but Days of
Future past was solid I can have things
that don't make sense that at least the
movie never explains I'm like how can
kitty pryde who walks through walls now
blasts people's consciousness back in
time alright you have that thing that
doesn't make sense but I'm gonna forget
about it because the rest of the movie
just thoroughly entertained me you have
a great moment with James McAvoy and
Patrick Stewart it really felt like a
passing of the torch which is really
what this movie was once again Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine is carrying this
movie also the franchise it was an
exciting adventure a great time travel
adventure it was great seeing this else
world fork in the road you still kind of
felt like oh we're in an alternate world
where mystique is good crazy little did
you know it wouldn't matter by the end
of all of it but still it felt cool at
the time regardless of what's become of
the x-men franchise because of the
shitty x-men movie this doesn't change
how great the good x-men movies
Days of Future past remains in that tear
next up x-men first class as what I was
talking about is it x-men first class or
Days of Future past what's above the
music in x-men first class things have
themes and I'm a sucker for themes like
magneto has a theme there's a theme for
cerebro when they're doing their montage
training there's a theme when Xavier and
Fassbender having romantic bromance
moments there's a theme not only that
but this movie came out swinging I
wasn't really looking forward to it
after x-men origins Wolverine there was
no way anyone was gonna convince me this
would be good dress I've got a great
x-men movie a proper x-men origins movie
where Xavier met magneto and they were
friends by the end of this movie totally
by the fact that these two friends have
found themselves on opposite sides of
this line takes place in the 60s in the
Cold War that's a compelling time and
Kevin Bacon totally crushed it as the
villain it humanized Charles Xavier
before this for me Charles Xavier was
this person who was just like he's on
this other pedestal this made me go oh
no Xavier is it he was a young dude
having fun doing a big beer shot the
path of Charles becoming the Xavier that
we know the path of Erik becoming
Magneto that we know it was damn
entertaining and compelling didn't
surprise the hell out of me because I
had written these x-men movies opera my
alright they're garbage now apparently
not this was the CP are the x-men
franchise needed for later burn instead
of drown onto number one number one
Logan are we surprised it was gonna be
Logan Logan's next level Logan was great
it was deep it was meaningful it was
human it was about human connection but
didn't lose the fact that this is still
an x-men movie this is the proper
concluding chapter to the x-men
franchise this is where it ended friends
this this is it did all the x-men die
off-screen yeah of course better than
the actual final installment Hugh
Jackman and Sir Patrick Stewart were
snubbed for nominations for those movie
I the acting was just it was crushing it
was heartbreaking it was funny cuz there
are a couple of curmudgeon ax sold dudes
are like Statler and Waldorf with claws
and a wheelchair did you cry at the end
I did I'm not afraid or ashamed to admit
it
it's the only x-men movie that made me
do that Logan's the best of the x-men
movies for me and it's also the proper
send-off to the x-men franchise also
ends our list that's it that's my
ranking of the x-men movies from worst
to best
based on my very subjective opinion
please do keep in mind this is just my
just how I feel it's how I see them and
if there's one franchise that's so
divisive it's the x-men franchise I've
seen people be like the best is the
Wolverine or the worst as Days of Future
past it's like it's so varied so for me
and my wedge of reality as I'm saying it
this is my list and as this is a top 10
list some people will love some people
will hate if you like this video or at
least if you appreciate it in any
capacity if you can click that like
button that'll help the video out thus
helps the channel out you've been doing
that lately it has been helping but did
you see Dark Phoenix what did you think
about it did you like it more than I did
did you hate it more than I did and if
you want to rank your x-men movies who
all of it comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]